[Music]
well this is a very exciting today we're
getting a sneak peek at a very popular
game Splinter Cell Black List I wanted
to take this very seriously so I brought
in somebody who's a real fan of this
particular game
say hello to J Cole yeah he's Emmy no
Grammy nominated not Emmy Grammy nominee
soon you don't want an Emmy those are
career deaf I have one it killed me do
you know this game yeah I played it in
college this was a long time ago I don't
know this game this is you played the
old for the older version in college it
was just 2pac men yeah exactly very
crude version yeah since this is one of
those ones where they're gonna start off
with a film that tells us a story yeah
how did you know that because every
single one of these games starts with a
40 minute film so this is like the
terrorist group you think America can't
find you
no need general ah you know I wouldn't
have spoken up at that point I would
have kept my mouth shut
yeah the main character is Sam Fisher
that's who you're playing ass is that
him that's him he's retired though he's
out of the army they're always here yeah
favorite ah why did he retire he just
wanted his pension tired of being great
yeah and there's a tower this is paladin
0-2 requesting permission to live doc
you notice it's these guys it's such
good animation but they're slightly
cross-eyed
that's it game over I think the game
starts so the game starts yeah you want
to well yeah I saw what to do
follow your friend Vic look at that a
little light went off on his sweater
okay so how do I shoot you'll have a gun
right now but when you run Sam Fisher
went to go get terrorists and he didn't
bring a gun but he brought his little
light-up sweater it's what Urban
Outfitters look at me right now you need
a boost
yeah friend up your own way what's that
hey okay you get a little closer there
you go okay now it looks like I'm just
looking at stocks
this looks bad I know I'm just running
around whoa whoa how frustrating is it
to play with me be honest am I like a
two-year-old like one and a half all you
need to do is disable the voltage
oscillator and disrupt the competing
signal so they're stealing cable they're
stealing DirecTV signal hello Lucy Anna
Grimm's daughter that's a terrible last
name what an awful rinse daughter now
did she ever have a relationship with
Sam do we know if they hooked up in the
past I don't know
but jazz is not the body language and
the cross ties
Grimm listen Sam we have a lot of work
ahead of us I thought maybe we should
clear the air yes for his history you
know what he's doing he's thinking about
lunch that's how I am
you have pasta that's gonna sit with me
all day salad and fruit that's not gonna
really stick with me lately afternoon
hey we're gonna go here we go
then gauzy Libya we're gonna get to the
safe house and extract this guy we think
my chances are of accomplishing any of
this be honest I'm gonna guess we didn't
liberate that guy unless he got away
during all the excitement you take over
I can't I I'm too terrible at this this
time you much sneak hear about going in
there yeah that was smart okay that was
great that was amazing you just shot
three guys there's laundry you can do
laundry
you never know you're gonna see another
washing machine we're gonna live there
they should spruce this place up a bit
we take one second to straighten out
that rug oh is that covin right there or
is this a fraternity initiation
okay we've established that Cole is very
good at this game
I a little less so
improve if we play together so we're
gonna go co-op you've got my back I got
you I would say I have your back but I'm
not good at turning around follow me
could a helicopter have dropped us on
top of this thing
target neutralized so you did all the
work
yes did a rock wall at REI oh I'm in
some weeds what are you doing you're
killing people I'm just seeing these
weeds how are you I'm dead Jason Cole
was killed in UK you know what I wasn't
you know why I hid in the weeds did I
help you much as a partner in that
situation um and be honest no I got a
song called letting Isles down you let
co down brother I let Cole down yeah but
I know that if we were to get in that
same situation again which we would I
would hide in the weeds again okay call
Splinter Cell blacklist I thought you
played really well what do you think of
the game I liked it a lot minute what
kind of rating would you give it on the
scale from who's like your favorite
artist of all time I'm a very big Tupac
fan the 2pi it's definitely a Tupac
range this is too far maybe and in terms
of Tupac albums is it's a negative
that's a pretty great rating yeah and on
my scale of music
I'll give this Kay Kyser's Spurs that
jingle jangle I cannot thank you
[Applause]
[Music]